- We're drinking Gaga drinks.
(chuckles)
- These drinks are Gaga!
(upbeat music)
I'm expecting a lot of
flash, because Lady Gaga's
very flashy and I love that.
- Pretty colors.
- Although I will say she's-
- Fun.
- She is very calm these days.
- Yeah, she got more calm like recently.
- She was like very theatrical before.
And now she's just kinda like glamorous.
I'm willing to try for Gaga.
(playful electronic music)
- [Kelsey] This is kind
of what I expected.
- [Evan] I expected like, mermaid frappe.
- No, that's old Lady Gaga.
- Not today's Lady Gaga?
- Today's Lady Gaga's more refined
and serious, like you said.
- Okay.
- Mmm!
- Oh, it's good!
- It's got lime, coconut milk.
- That's what it is.
It's like a pink tea, watered
down and a little milky
with a hint of lime.
- I like this.
I can drink this everyday.
This is good.
- [Kelsey] What, what, what
is this? I'm about this.
So if you're wanting a green tea,
this would be disappointing
because it's definitely not.
But the more I drink it
actually, the more I'm like,
oh, it's like a nice tea with a lemon,
and the tea happens to be Matcha tea.
- It's more lemonade than Matcha.
- I only taste Matcha.
- [Kelsey] You're crazy.
(laughs)
- I love Starbucks' Green Tea Frappuccino.
- [Kelsey] That's mostly
not green tea as well.
- Oh, really?
- Kelsey, have you worked
at Starbucks before?
- I don't order anything but
dark coffee at Starbucks.
- [Evan] You're very like...
- Maybe it's just confidence.
I'm just very opinionated. (laughs)
(heavy rock music)
- [YB] Blackberries and tart hibiscus.
- [Kelsey And Evan] Hibiscus.
- [YB] Hibiscus.
- [Evan] What is that?
- [Kelsey] It's a flower.
- [YB] Oh, it's flowers.
- [Evan] Of course you know.
(laughs)
- I have no idea what
this is gonna taste like.
This is pretty sweet, but I
actually kinda don't hate it.
I like that there's berries in it.
That makes me happy.
- I know you're into berries. Yeah.
Hibis- (babbles).
- You got this.
- Hibiscus, hibiscus?
- Hibiscus.
- [Both] Hibiscus.
- Tart hibis- (babbles).
Ah, It's hard.
- A berry berry hibiscus
Starbucks refresher.
- It takes me to different
places each time.
- There's a lot of different
flavors going on at once.
- There is a lot of different flavors.
- There's like a flower-y flavor,
there's a little bit of
milk from the coconut milk.
- I taste cinnamon.
- Hmm?
- Am I crazy?
- I think you're crazy.
- Maybe I am.
(laughs)
- Also I bet sweetness
comes from the berry, no?
- I think the sweetness is
added, like simple syrup.
And then I think there's probably
some kind of hibiscus tea.
- You say it so easily.
- [YB] I know, (babbles),
Evan and I are like-
- (laughs) We're like, hibiscus-cus-cus.
And you're just like, hibiscus.
(bright pop music)
- If you had strawberry
ice cream and melted it
and then put some strawberries on top,
that's what it looks like to me.
If it tastes like that, it
wouldn't be the worst thing.
- [Kelsey] Should we get
pictures really fast?
- [YB] Can we?
- [Evan] Alright we have to stop the shoot
because they have to Instagram.
(laughs)
- Yup!
- Cheers!
Cheers cheers!
- I'm glad we match our drinks today, YB.
- Mmm, this is good too!
Oh it's like, it tastes like yogurt.
- It tastes like strawberry yogurt.
If you're looking for kind of like
a dessert type of drink, something sweet,
something refreshing, this is good.
YB approved.
- I approved 100%.
You know all of these
drinks would be really good
as a frappuccino.
- We'd all had so many frappes,
so maybe we were frapped out
and they wanted- frapped out!
(laughs) Frapped out!
I think my favorite would
have to be the last one,
the pink drink.
It's pink.
Strawberries in it.
Stop, stop that Evan.
(laughs)
Stop that right now, stop.
- Definitely the berry one.
- Berry?
- Berry, yes, the violet one.
- I think mine's between the ombre pink
or the pink drink.
They're both really good.
- [Evan] I feel like you like this better.
- Yeah, maybe I...
- [Evan] You had better
reaction when you drink this.
- Did I, really?
Okay, I like this better.
- Signing off.
- Signing off you guys.
Peace.
(cheerful wind music)